[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to a brand
new attack on Titan video thank you so
much for all the crazy support for our
latest attack on Titan video in which we
talked about why we think that dinosaurs
are shown in the attack on Titan season
2 opening in this video we are going to
be talking about the ninth and final
Titan shifter the Warhammer Titan we
first learned about the Warhammer Titan
in Chapter 95 of the manga we were told
that this Titan Power has been possessed
by the tiber family for generations
however we know very little about the
unique powers of the Warhammer Titan and
I saw a bunch of disappointed comments
from people who were hoping that the 9th
Titan shifter would be something cool
like a flying Titan or an underwater
Titan and these comments were saying
things like great job Issei Yama you
could have made the ninth Titan
something cool but you made him a Titan
that just holds a freaking hammer other
people jokingly called the ninth Titan
shifter the Thor Titan but this joke
might not be so far from the truth in
this video we will look at the evidence
from the attack on Titan manga and extra
material including the information we
have so far about the special powers of
the eight other Titan shifters in order
to present a theory on what the
Warhammer Titans true power might be I
want to thank so mahkum Yves peeve and
Aron Yaga for their feedback in the
anime theories channel of our discord
server and if you want to talk about
anime theories and contribute to future
videos you can join our discord server
as well link in the description and now
if you are psyched and ready to go be
sure to war hammer smash that like
button and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell in chapter 95 of the
manga we learned at the tiber family the
holders of the Warhammer Titan Power is
a family of Albion aristocrats who
opposed king fritz when he decided to
move the capital of aldea to paradise a
hundred years ago and supposedly for
this reason they were given preferential
treatment by the Marlon government
unlike other ldiots who are forced to
live in internment zones the Tiber
family are considered honorary Marlon's
and they live in
mansions on big estates even stranger
than this is the fact that the timers
have controlled the power of the
Warhammer Titan this whole time but they
never once used this power to help
Marlay against an enemy state we know
how the Malayan government treats LD ins
we know how hated the LD ins are as the
so called spawn of the devil and we know
that the Marlin army has gone to extreme
lengths to use the power of the Titans
in their wars with other nations even
when that means sacrificing the lives of
innocent LD and civilians and children
so could it really be that this same
Marlon government is just so grateful to
the Tiber family for opposing the 145th
King 100 years ago that they not only
let them live freely as rich aristocrats
while every other LDN is forced to live
in internment zones but they're also
perfectly fine with the Tiber family
keeping the power of the Warhammer Titan
to themselves instead of using it to
help Marlay fight its wars with other
nations from everything we know about
the Malayan government and its treatment
of aliens this makes no sense the only
way that this whole situation would make
any sense is if the Marlon government is
not grateful to the Tiber family but
afraid of the power of the Warhammer
Titan if the Warhammer Titans power is
so strong that it poses a huge threat to
Marlay then it would make sense for the
Marlon government to negotiate a deal
with the Tiber family a deal in which
the Tiber czar allowed to live lavishly
and keep the Titan power for themselves
but what could the Warhammer Titan
secret power possibly be if it can scare
the Malayan government into making such
an uncharacteristic compromise remember
earlier when I mentioned the Thor Titan
we know that the worldö attack on titan
and the power of the titans itself is
strongly influenced by norse mythology
and of course in Norse mythology Thor is
a hammer wielding God associated with
thunder lightning and storms according
to Norse mythology Thor's hammer called
the Mjolnir is one of the most powerful
weapons in existence and it is able to
level entire mountains now we know that
every Titan shifter has a certain unique
power and ability
the Colossus Titan is huge and extremely
strong and has
to generate steam and massive explosions
the armored Titan of course has really
strong armor
ja Titan is quick and agile the female
Titan has impressive endurance and the
ability to call other Titans to her the
founding Titan can control other Titans
and so on so what if the secret power of
the Warhammer Titan is that like Thor he
has the power to generate or control
lightning or electricity we already know
that when humans transform into Titans
something very similar to flashes of
lightning appears so it would not be so
far-fetched to think that a Titan can
have the ability to generate and control
lightning and if this were the case it
would explain why the Malayan government
would fear the Warhammer Titan don't
forget that unlike the LDN some parodies
Marlay relies far more on modern
technology for everything ships blimps
trains planes and weapons and what type
of weapon could do the most damage to
this kind of technology a weapon that
harnesses the power of lightning or
electricity I'm sure you know the type
of damage that a sudden power surge can
cause to household appliances and
devices so imagine what a massive surge
of concentrated electric power could do
to Marlin technology what if the real
reason that the Marlins despite their
deep-seated hatred for the LDN race
allow the Tiber family to live as
aristocrats and keep the Warhammer Titan
power for themselves is that they are
afraid that the secret power of the
Warhammer Titan could cause terrible
damage to their technology perhaps even
destabilize entire cities if this
happened Marley would be vulnerable to
attacks from rival nations who would
want to take advantage of their weakness
so rather than risk trying to confront
the tiburce the Malayan government
decided to simply deal with the Tiber
family to make a deal with them in
return I imagined that the Tiber family
agreed not to interfere with the
terrible treatment of the other LD ends
by the Marlon government and if you
think I'm crazy to say that attack on
Titan would draw so heavily from Norse
mythology as to give the Warhammer Titan
powers similar to Thor consider this in
Norse mythology the first living being
that was ever created was a giant called
Amir yes you heard that right why am I
our Emir the exact same name as the
first Titan shifter in attack on Titan
Emir fritz this Emir from norse
mythology was also a progenitor as he
created the yacht not a race of frost
giants these giants are closely
associated with natural phenomena like
bad weather and storms and some stories
claim that Giants can move and create
mountains form lakes move islands and
uproot trees select the Titans of aldea
they could potentially build an entire
empire just looking at the way that the
Giants and gods were depicted in Norse
mythology we see a huge similarity to
how Emir Fritz and the Titans are
portrayed in drawings within the world
of attack on Titan and by the way did
you notice this image from the attack on
Titan season 2 closing credits this
image appears to show amir fritz in
Titan form rising out of the sea and
preparing to fight an enemy army but do
you see the thick clouds and lightning
all around her now maybe it is just a
coincidence that a giant storm is raging
at the same time that Emir appeared but
maybe it's actually a hint that like in
Norse mythology which so heavily
influenced attack on Titan Amir's Titan
had the power to control the weather and
lightning in particular if this was the
case when Amir's titan power was split
between the nine Titan shifters the
ability to control lightning could have
passed on to the Warhammer tight and
speaking of the nine Titan shifters did
you know that in Norse mythology there
is a ring called the dropped near that
belonged to the god Odin the father of
Thor
according to legend on every ninth night
this ring would multiply itself and
create eight new rings so instead of one
ring we would get nine rings just like
Amir's Titan power was transferred from
her into nine Titan shifters there is
also something like an equivalent to the
coordinate in Norse mythology the in
Drasil or the world tree appears to
connect the nine different worlds in
Norse mythology in a similar way that
the coordinate connects all LD ins
through past the transcend physical
space and since the world of attack on
Titan is clearly so heavily influenced
by Norse mythology I don't think it's
too much of a stretch to think
that the Warhammer Titan is directly
inspired by Thor who is known for his
famous hammer and the ability to control
lightning as I mentioned earlier this
would explain why the Malayan government
has given such special treatment to the
Tiber family compared to all other LD
ins if the Warhammer Titan has the power
to harness lightning or electricity the
damage it could cause - Marlin
technology is a strong motivation for
the Marlins to make a deal with the
timers in our previous video called why
we see dinosaurs in the attack on Titan
Season 2 opening we talked about how all
of the Titan shifters appear to have
certain special abilities based on the
abilities of different animals so for
example the beast Titan closely
resembles an ape
jaws is like a chimpanzee but with teeth
and resemble an alligator or dinosaur
the armored Titan and other Titans can
harden their skin like some animals can
for example turtles who have a hard
shell the female Titan can call other
Titans to her with a cry like many
animals can do with mating calls and so
on and although the secret power of the
Warhammer Titan might at first appear to
contradict this theory since no animal
can harness the power of lightning it is
important to remember that certain
animals like electric eels can actually
generate electricity so even for this
type of power there are some examples in
nature and so that is our theory about
the secret power of the Warhammer Titan
and why the Tiber family was able to
escape persecution by the Marlon
government and keep the Warhammer Titan
power to themselves for so long but this
is just a theory of course we can't know
for sure yet so I invite all of you to
let us know why your own theories are
down below it could also be possible
that the Tiber family no longer
possesses the Warhammer Titan but
because everyone still believes that
they do they continue to enjoy the
benefits if this was the case and
someone stole the power of the Warhammer
Titan from them just like owl managed to
steal the power of the attack Titan then
someone within the walls could possess
the ninth titan power maybe even someone
we already know for now this is just
speculation of course still some of the
best attack on Titan theories I've heard
come out of the comments sections to our
videos which is amazing and I encourage
all of you to keep up the great
discussions a huge thank you to all of
our anime up
patrons for helping to make these videos
possible including shadows Gilgamesh
third-strike Sinead Oh Christian floor
or bono AMS original ink and manga and
if you would like to consider supporting
the channel the patreon link is in the
description every bit helps even a
single dollar as always thank you all so
much for watching and for the continued
support it really means a lot to us and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]